in the first movie for Gomorrah it was
pretty much get through from Santos or
die trying
where do we find her now um now she's a
part of a family and she's taken on the
mother role which is to keep them
focused and keep them from killing each
other
reminding them that we're here to always
do good so he appears on the outside of
the mystery food and what will fix it
from the inside is from the outside I
realized that you know James gem gave me
a direction that was almost impossible
for me to assimilate and it was like
you're your gamora's like Clint Eastwood
and I'm like oh no cuz in my mind I was
like I've never seen a Clint Eastwood
movie I don't know what it's like to be
so emotionless you know but he's like
that's that's your reference that's
Clint Eastwood so every day I would wake
up and I'm like I'm Clint Eastwood Karen
Gillan said that she learned from being
on site with you all the time you had
some great advice for her what some of
the stuff that you passed along to
always talked to James if she doesn't
feel comfortable doing but not back but
she doesn't have to prove anything to
anybody
just because I'm doing something for her
to not feel that pressure that she has
to do it I get a kick out of falling
down and picking myself back again and
trying again and for Karen for her to
tell James like I want to do this and
let her stuntwoman like do it is perfect
but there's so many things that I also
learned from Karen you know it's here to
just have fun
she just transforms a pensioner Beulah
every time James says action and then
when he says cut it's like she's back to
being her goofy old stuff I was like
what is this nebula Karen it's fantastic
so there's a lot of inspiration that I
have when I work with Kari
you